we're told corn is used as food and as
an input in the production of ethanol
and alternative fuel
assume corn is produced in a perfectly
competitive market
draw correctly labeled side-by-side
grass for the corn market and a
representative corn farmer
on your graphs show each of the
following the equilibrium price and
quantity in the corn market labeled p
sub m and q sub m respectfully
respectively
the profit maximizing quantity of corn
produced by the representative farmer
earning zero economic profit labeled q
sub f
so like always pause this video and see
if you can do this on your own before we
work through it together all right now
let's work through it together so we're
going to do correctly labeled side by
side graphs
so let me do
this is going to be my horizontal axis
for the market and then this is going to
be the horizontal axis
for the farmer
and this is going to be
quantity in the market
quantity
quantity and then this is going to be
for the farmer quantity
and then this is going to be price in
the market and whatever the market price
is that's also going to be the price
that the farmer has to take because it
says it's a perfectly competitive market
so the farmer is going to be a price
taker here
so let me make these axes
so this is price
right over here and this is price over
here
so first let's draw the corn market so
let me label this corn
market
and we've done this multiple times
already our demand curve might look
something like this this is our demand
curve
as
when price is high low quantity demanded
when price is low high quantity demanded
and supply goes the other way around so
our supply curve would look something
like this
and then this point this helps us figure
out this is going to be our equilibrium
price so that's p sub m
p sub m and then this is going to be
our equilibrium quantity
so q sub m
now this graph over here we are going to
draw the farmer so this is going to be
the
the farmer
the farmer's firm right over here so the
farmer is going to be a price taker so
whatever the equilibrium price in the
market that is going to be the price
that the farmer
is going to have to take that market
price is going to be the farmer's
marginal revenue
now they say the profit maximizing
quantity of corn produced by the farmer
by the represented farmer earning zero
economic profit labeled q sub apps we're
gonna have some quantity right over here
it is the profit maximizing quantity but
it's also zero economic profit
so the zero economic profit tells us
that the price must be equal to the
average total cost at that quantity so i
can make an average total cost curve
that looks something like this
and i'm going to make its minimum point
intersect that market price
because we know from previous videos
that the profit maximizing quantity
happens where the marginal cost
intersects the marginal revenue which in
this case would be the price that the
farmer has to take from the market and
we know that the marginal cost curve
intersects the average total cost curve
at this minimum point right over here so
i could draw a
marginal cost curve it might look
something like this
so that is our
marginal cost curve and notice the
marginal cost curve intersects the
average total cost at that minimum point
we explain that in multiple videos
already and we've explained in a
previous video that the profit
maximizing quantity is the quantity at
which the marginal cost and the marginal
revenue meet and the price is the
marginal revenue beyond that point every
incremental unit the corn farmer is
going to take a loss it's going to take
them more resources to produce that corn
than they were they're going to be able
to get in the market
and we also mentioned that this has to
be a situation of zero economic profit
so the average total cost has to be at
that price at that marginal revenue
right at that point so this right over
here
would be
our
q
sub
capital f
and we're done